this continent is going through a period
of change Africa needs to create 20
million jobs by 2035 and while youth
unemployment is a global challenge it's
particularly a problem here when nearly
57 percent of young people are
unemployed starting out of life in this
way can start a cycle poverty that could
be difficult to escape but you guys are
producing solutions and for that we
commend you for this reason I'm
incredibly proud to share that the UK is
going to provide eight million pounds
for skills for Prosperity program
working with the South African
government and others this program is
going to maximize African ingenuity with
UK support to fill the gap between
skills that employers urgently need and
the training offered to employees in my
role as the Queen's Commonwealth Youth
Ambassador I am so incredibly fortunate
to meet young people who are determined
to make a real difference and make their
mark on the world through action meeting
people like you makes me realize that
the world is in good hands
we're going to see a president this
afternoon as well and we will tell him
what we have seen and heard and it is so
great to see South Africa and the UK
relationship so strong I've often talked
about Africa as my second home and I've
often been asked why I love it so much
well over the last nine days I've been
trying to put my feelings and
experiences into words which which is
not easy I wanted to try and answer a
more specific question for myself what
is the essence of Africa why is it that
so many visitors feel Africa gets under
our skin and into our soul
last night I returned from my third
visit to the fourth poorest country in
the world
Malawi despite extreme hardship and
ongoing challenges on so many levels
people are generous they are strong
humble and incredibly optimistic I know
that there are daily struggles that most
of us couldn't be
to imagine yet I've seen strength
resilience and a sense of hope and
empathy that I can only aspire to
replicate ever since I came to this
country as a young boy trying to cope
with something I could never possibly
describe Africa has helped me in an
embrace that I will never forget and I
feel incredibly fortunate for that and
every time I come here I know that I'm
not alone I always feel wherever I am on
this continent but the community around
me provides a life that is enriching and
is rooted in the simple simplest things
connection connections with others and
the natural environment and as I raised
my own son I want to make sure that what
I've learned here the value of the
natural world
the value of community and friendship is
something that I can pass on to him next
year we launched our new foundation man
it's moments like today and meeting all
of you that inspire us whether it's
supporting young entrepreneurs and
powering women and girls or challenging
the issue of gender-based violence
whether it's been planting trees
clearing land mines or protecting the
most beautiful creatures and places on
this planet
these experiences have affirmed our love
of Africa I mean issues that are so
important to us